thick black smoke rose up from the
village and below the fire ripped
through buildings flames so fierce and
so high nothing could stop them
spreading with dangerous and terrifying
speed
it started in wellington green um
caught fire and compost heap the wind's
not helped found flames it's
gone right across the village taking out
the uh everyone on the green staying at
the church and slowly moving its way
along the main roads
just after we spoke to andrew the fire
moved so fast we pulled away the air now
dark with smoke
terrified residents were unable to stop
the spread so it's been really scary i
was even tearing i was crying my little
one was crying as well blessing was at
home with her two-month-old baby when
the police told her to leave i don't
even know what to say because i've never
seen i used to see this kind of fires on
tv i never thought in my in my wildest
dream that would happen to us i've been
so scared but thank god we've seen some
passerbys who've been giving us water
and stuff
fanned by wind but fueled by brittle dry
ground the flames were impossible to
stop with lives at risk the whole
village was evacuated
my partner has got copd
he can't breathe he's not allowed at the
house
and he's panicking so the police officer
just got hold of him and and we have to
go at the house and just shut the door
after us residents in this rural village
are in shock the heatwave brought fire
and left people here homeless and
unimaginable trauma i was actually
upstairs at the time and i actually saw
from my window like the flames really
close to the house so
naturally very very panicked only had a
chance to grab my phone nothing else we
don't know 100 for sure but we have been
told that there is a very high
possibility that our house is
already gone they gathered at a local
pub now evacuation center
firefighters are used to extreme
temperatures but the ferocity of this
fire was something else we've probably
never seen
weather-related incidents particularly
to do with heat on this scale before but
we do have well-rehearsed and practiced
plans in place to be able to make sure
that we're prioritizing our resources
as winds change direction they fought to
contain and control the flames
people on the ground doing all they
could to help
the air is still filled with the smell
of smoke and you can see a cloud of it
hanging over the horizon above the
village and if you take a look at the
fields behind me you can see why this
fire spreads so quickly the grass here
is so dry it's crunchy to the touch
as night fell the fire still burned we
were warned the heat wave would bring
danger
but no one expected something like this
laura bundock sky news wentington
extraordinary pictures and laura has
been here for much of the day she's with
me now what was it like at the height of
this fire it was almost unbelievable
when we arrived in the village we were
alongside a field right at the edge of
the fire and i think the thing that
struck everyone there was just how fast
it was moving there were these giant
plumes of smoke literally racing through
the fields and i think the fact you
could see how fast they were moving
really heightened that sense of danger
that was when the village was evacuated
and you had these people here who
suddenly had this major incident right
on their doorstep they had literally
nowhere to go which is why we saw the
pub over the road become this sort of
pop-up refuge center the police set up
desks in there they were checking off
names they wanted to make sure everyone
was accounted for and inside there were
children there were babies there were
pets there are a couple of parrots even
almost a surreal scene and very quickly
i think that initial fear the initial
fright turned to action and that's when
we started seeing people taken to hotels
nearby we saw the rest center set up as
well which is where people have also
been taken but i think what's hardest is
the fire is far from out at the moment
it is still burning tonight you can see
these pictures now it's incredible
think how many hours it's been burning
and you've got people the whole village
unable to go home with no idea when
they'll make it back and no idea what
kind of a state they'll find their homes
in you can see how close it is to other
properties to other buildings here
it's astonishing and i think the way it
spreads so quickly that the brittleness
of the ground here is why we've seen
such an extreme event we were told this
extreme temperature would cause an
extreme event but this is the very very
real image of it right now okay laura
thank you very much and not more fire
trucks
arriving new
fire
engines arriving all the time laura
thank you very much